would you like to have some tea with me
[Music]
[Music]
yes i would love to have some tea review
so you have some options here i'll let
you pick first
i'm a big mint tea oh are you okay yes
i've been eyeing this one the vanilla
chai oh i've had that is it good yes
okay should i let me pour the pea first
what kind of
videos do you normally do yeah so my
favorite see or i guess my most popular
series is this one i do where i have
people ask share secret
and i'm filming the back of their head
so you don't see them
and yeah so maybe we could start there
do you have like a little secret oh my
a secret
it's really hot so be careful i didn't
realize it'd be this hot we might have
to wait like
that's okay i actually really like when
it's
my secret is that maybe i like to
secretly be burned
i swear to god me too
like my my soup has to be like scalding
hot or i can't eat it my tea it can't be
warm it has to be hot so
your name's autumn um is there a reason
your parents gave you that name um i was
born on the first day of fall
yeah my parents didn't really have a
name for me
and i think i was nameless for like a
few hours actually
and then they like were looking at the
calendar and they saw it was the first
day of fall that's such a cool story
and my last name is ivy oh so autumn ivy
like is perfect together
yeah this is like my favorite place in
san diego
oh kate's session
this is just my second time here oh
really yeah oh this is like a like maybe
every other weekend vibe for me i'll
just come and
hang out see i wish i was like that i
don't do every time i have free time i
just like sit on my couch
it's easy to do that i do that too
sometimes too but like i especially just
because i'm new to the area i really try
to like get out and do
something that's like meaningful
have you made friends doing stuff like
that or
it's funny we were just discussing this
um i've been here for a year and i
really
she's like my only friend oh really yeah
if you have a good friend you know
that's all you need right it doesn't
matter yeah but like recently i've been
trying to like
get out and be more social it's just
easy to like
be by yourself sometimes
but
yes let me look through my list of
questions here yeah i usually ask really
deep and personal questions that's fine
i love that that's what we just did for
the past two hours
and you said you were talking about
going doing things outside your comfort
zone yes and then that's when i came up
too it's perfect
is there anyone you need to forgive
you're starting right off the bat
heavy hitters right
um
[Music]
is there
yeah are you willing to share you don't
have to
makes you a little nervous
yeah sorry i don't want to get emotional
no it's fine i mean
if like
it's a i'm an emotional person anything
we were just also discussing this um i
think that the biggest person i need to
forgive is myself okay
um i think that
i in the past few years have forgiven
other people
so that i don't have to carry that
weight
and then
you know i still have a little bit of
forgiveness to give myself
um but yeah that would be that would be
my person i think okay
yeah sorry geez thanks for sharing that
with me yeah of course um so so you
do you feel like you have been forgiving
yourself or taking steps towards that
yeah yeah and how are you doing that
um being gentle with myself
is definitely something that
i've like just been trying to make a
priority in my life
um
i guess i do that in ways like stopping
and thinking about when i'm in a loop in
my head like
you don't deserve this you don't deserve
this
yeah i do i've done this i've done this
i've worked hard for this feeling or
this opportunity
or even just this life in general that
saying to be gentle with yourself that's
so sweet like i'm gonna tell myself that
from now on damn
we really did start off yeah that was i
wasn't expecting that
at all
um okay so
next question
is uh maybe a little more lighthearted
hopefully what is the song that reminds
you of someone you love oh that's sweet
okay so my dad and i connect
very
we communicate through music okay i was
actually just telling her this that
he'll send me a song and then i know
exactly how he's feeling if you would
look through her messages it's like
spotify spotify spotify like you don't
even write we don't even have to write
things um
but one that we send pretty frequently
would be woods by mac miller it touches
my soul like it speaks to my soul i love
it the first line is things like this
weren't meant to last
so i think that you could kind of take
that anyway
hi hi you want to have two with those
kids
do you like your butt scratched
[Music]
hey pickleball buddy oh my god how are
you
that's tada
yeah i'm having a tea with the stranger
today
what are the chances
that's funny so i recently started
playing pickleball
so anyway
so we play pickleball with strangers and
she's one of them what are the chances i
know that's actually the universe today
is like really weird i'm getting really
weird energy today
not bad just kind of out there in a good
magical way right
so you said something earlier you said
that
sometimes you feel like you're not
deserving of things and even on the
large scale with something that you've
been wanting to do or what you've been
wanting but you felt like you've been
undeserving of it which i'm sure you are
deserving of
oh boy
i'm gonna start at the top okay large
would probably be like own a home
i think a lot of people will probably
feel like that right um
i i didn't ever think that it would be
so out of reach for me to like own a
home one day i don't know like how hard
do i have to work like to deserve to own
a home you know like i work really hard
and i'm nowhere near it so that would
probably be at the top for me when did
you realize you were not like everyone
else
oh
i think that
what would make me different is that i'm
very empathetic
i've i call it my superpower sometimes
um
i don't know that's a good way to be
different i think yeah i'd say do you
think you were born that way or do you
think that was like the way you were
raised i think it's a product of my
environment i've actually talked about
this in therapy and because i didn't
realize it until somebody told me you
didn't realize that you were super
empathetic
no okay um i thought that i well i
thought that i was really good at
reading people which i would say that i
am
but i actually realized that it's like
the product of my household was
to
kind of guess how people were feeling
so that i could react
accordingly
so if somebody was in a bad mood i could
tell by the way that they were walking
the the steps on the floor upstairs oh
they're upset the way that the door
closes they call it fortune telling in
therapy
that you're like fortune telling
so it can be good
like when you're connecting with
somebody like i know how you're feeling
like i feel that for you that kind of
thing but it can also be like harmful
for you because you're constantly trying
to guess is this person upset are they
okay what can i do about it you just
have to like sit right in the middle of
it and like know when to take yourself
out of it and be like okay how am i
feeling because like that has nothing to
do with me you know yeah and have you
been doing that yes
yes
past few years for sure that's so crazy
so you could you would be able to tell
just by like how someone was walking at
your house like yeah that is a
superpower
well i mean when that's all you know is
the sound of somebody's footprint or
footprints footsteps coming in the door
what kind of mood they're in
it kind of just tells you more about the
household than it does you it's just
like you
like evolving to like
the environment so definitely a product
of my environment i don't think i was
born like that definitely
oh okay you going yeah
what do you think your purpose
in life is
well it's a
big one
i really do think my purpose
was to like do what i'm doing now yeah
yeah meeting strangers
sharing stories yeah yeah it's really
incredible
you would never
i would have just kept sitting up there
and being like what are they doing down
there
if you wouldn't have come up so
yeah it's cool you're like making
memories for other people and yourself i
love that when people say that they'll
remember this it's like so crazy because
i like obviously all remember it but
like i always forget that like other
people
it's a shared experience yeah
why do you think we met oh
um
i think ev like this whole day
has been like meant to be honestly i
don't know why
um i think it was really cool to be very
introspective today and think about
things i haven't thought about in a long
time also like you're really cool and i
would totally hang out with you so and i
was just saying like i want to have like
more friends here i don't get out enough
so like maybe that was the universe
today being like hey check like a few
things off your box
your list this like today because
like everything has been like in line
with everything we talked about today
it's kind of crazy right off the bat too
yeah and then like honestly i couldn't
have
picked a better first person because
i've been like really struggling getting
into filming again and i'm so glad
you're like the first person no i'm glad
i was too it was fun i actually have
wait up this has your name on it
that's weird
wait what
you want to open it
i don't know where that came from
oh what is it
you have to read the letter
[Music]
should we hug it out
oh
you're gonna make me cry it's
not you so much
stop crying i'm gonna cry too
i don't have words
thank you so the letter says
hey autumn
hope you have as many
trips to kate sessions as possible and
that you take many well-deserved
relaxing days
the world also helps you reach your goal
of owning a home it may not be much but
here is 200 towards your home you're so
deserving thank you for sharing today
thank you that has to be your first 200
dollars for saying it it's going
straight into savings i can't tell you
that
any ending thoughts because i have 2
million subscribers so
anything you want to tell them
um take risks
um
i don't know
take risks if i didn't do this today i
mean i wouldn't have developed this
connection with a stranger
um
yeah
love deeply
listen
to others and
be gentle with you be gentle with
yourself that's my favorite thing
that you said today thank you so much
[Applause]
wow
i love that actually can i have you what
was going on through your head when you
like did when you gave me the letter
yeah oh i just thought it was another
one of like
weird ass things that have happened
today that's like everything is like in
the universe like
i was like wow you have my name on a
letter
that's crazy wow
[Music]